hi everyone my name is philip i'm the
tech lead for hugging phase infinity
infinity is our new enterprise scale
inference solution which can be run
anywhere where a container can run from
public clouds to on-premise server
delivering down to one millisecond
latency on bird-like transformer models
today i will show you in a few minutes
how you can optimize a bird-like model
from the hugging phase hub with infinity
multiverse and run inference on it
afterwards using the infinity container
the first step is
going to the hugging phase hub and
selecting our model we are going to use
a sentence transformer fine tune for
document embeddings we are going to use
the mini lm one from niels who is the
maintainer of the sentinel transformer
library we are copying on the model id
and then switching to our
terminal
here i'm logged in on an ec2
g4dnx large
running in nvidia t4 gpu
and to optimize our model we are going
to use infinity multiverse infinity
multiverse is another container solution
which comes with infinity which allows
you to optimize bird-like models for the
infinity container by defining a few cli
arguments
therefore to optimize our model we
define our hardware in this case it's an
nvidia gpu so we have as hardware nvidia
our accelerators gpu the task is
embedding the topology for the mini lm
is bird we have our model
with the model id and we want to push it
to the hub afterwards so when running
the inference we can directly load it
from the hugging phase hub instead of
providing it into the
container
we hit enter
after infinity multiverse has optimized
our model it has been uploaded to the
hub since we provided the push to up key
and if we take our look at our
repository on the hiking phase up you
can see it basically maintain the same
model name except that we like created a
new repository for it and then if we go
to files and versions we can see
multiverse has created our infidel
infinity model repository containing our
infinity model our tokenizer and the
config json providing the configuration
to run our model inside the infinity
container so now to run our model inside
infinity we are going to use the
infinity container
and provide our
image or our model
as storage uri
and infinity
will now load the model from the honey
phase hub
and starts the api
in addition to this i have created a
python script which has an input
requesting our endpoint to then see how
fast inference is for our model
you can run this with python3
and just need a
few more seconds until the api has
started
so the infinity api has now started now
i can start a request you can see first
this is an example output of our vector
for our embedding document and then we
can see our requests are taken between
1.4 milliseconds and 1.7 milliseconds
for a second length of 16 token
and in addition to this i also have
created another
python script containing a longer
sequence of 128 token and if we run this
script
we can see infinity is still maintaining
low latency with 2.3 to 2.6 millisecond
on the nvidia t4 gpu
thanks for watching and if you are
interested in trying out infinity feel
free to head to huggingface.com infinity
minus trial to sign up for your infinity
trial